hi guys I want to talk about blood
Sugars I want to talk about what is a
normal blood sugar well typically it's
between eighty and a hundred milligrams
per deciliter sometimes it could be
seventy if you're you know it can go
down if you're completely giving up
sugar can go even lower and that's a
total normal situation now what does
this mean eighty to a hundred
milliliters per deciliter basically that
means the ratio of how much sugar that
you have in your blood now an average
person of 165 pounds
has one in one-third gallons of blood in
their body okay gallon and one-third of
a gallon of blood and the if it was
normal let's say was ninety okay right
in the middle that would be kind of a
heaping slightly more than a teaspoon
not quite a heaping but slightly a
little bit more than a teaspoon of sugar
per all this blood okay that's if we
diluted that that would be ninety okay
that would be normal blood sugars and
you can actually convert protein and
even fat into sugar so you don't even
need carbs to get this normal ratio but
an average American consumes 31
teaspoons of sugar every single day
that's a hundred and thirty to 145
pounds of sugar a year and it has
lifetime
it's a dumpster full of sugar now this
is why most of the population is
becoming pre-diabetic and diabetic and
the problem is they don't know that
they're actually a diabetic yet or they
don't know they're a pre-diabetic
because it's not showing up on the blood
test okay it won't show up because it
starts off small and it gets worse and
worse and worse and then one day you
have it okay but some of the symptoms
are you know you get tired after you eat
you crave sweets you hat you're not
satisfied after you eat you can't go
many hours without eating and
when you eat you feel better that's a
pre-diabetic situation but you don't
need a lot of sugar in your diet to have
a normal blood sugar in fact I recommend
you go zero sugar and your sugars will
be you will clear up so many health
problems if you do that ok so here's to
two points I'm going to make you don't
need sugar ok like some people say well
doesn't your brain running a sugar no it
can run on fat it can run on other fuels
your body does not need sugar alright
put your comments below and I'll see you
in the next video
hey guys thank you so much for watching
I really appreciate it please click the
share button below and I will see you in
the next video